say hello to the camera I've decided to
make a bit of a devlog this week
so awesome a little camera
and uh yeah that's about it I just
wanted to
get that hopefully it was recording yep
[Music]
the sweet thing run I'm an entirely
separate process so we spin off a
separate process
and like just killing that process why
do we reload and the pre-starting
everything from scratch is that a viable
option because I feel like that may also
have other benefits such as for example
uh with the 140 multi-ending obviously
gizmos causes strange behavior on scale
I think like we're just about to scale
with gizmos because I checked how I'm
real I'm
this thing on
why is it
that's better
what's up welcome to
the devlog this is going to be a
hopefully weekly kind of show we'll say
on my channel where I just show document
what on Earth happens because to be
quite Frank I feel like we have been
doing as a team a terrible job of like
actually showing what on Earth we do
what it is we're doing with hazel I've
tried to do stuff like this before and I
don't think I've managed to stick to it
because it just takes up too much time
it just causes too much friction we'll
say the fact is we're a small team
there's three of us me Tim and Peter
aside from just working on Hazel I have
other things that I do such as make like
non-hazel related videos for YouTube
primarily and to be honest I've
struggled to make hazel devlogs like I
used to back in the day because I just
overthink it I end up spending all of my
time making videos and doing the media
production side of things and I run out
of time to actually work on Hazel which
is really frustrating so these are going
to be just really chill really back
frictionless frictionless is the key way
that's why I'm sitting here on the floor
and not on the actual couch it's to
signify the chill nature of these videos
deep and like honestly I kind of want to
be able to look back on these videos at
some point in my life and just see like
what it was like like what was life like
back then what was developing Hazel like
back then I think it's really cool to be
able to keep like a development log like
literally just for me even you guys
aside and I'm also feeling like it's
kind of a bit sad because when I look
back at those old videos of the Hazel
devlog that used to exist over the years
like it's just well for one it's really
inconsistent which is a shame you can't
kind of see it evolve over the months
but also like to me I don't think it's
as enjoyable to watch because I just
spent all my time talking about the code
and showing stuff rather than also
including like what life was like back
then which is why I'm hoping to
intertwine this a bit with b-roll maybe
even a bit of my personal life as well
just so that it really is like almost a
log of
my life in a way it's like devlog the
devlog is me I'm the thing being
developed so yeah hope you guys enjoy
the footage in the beginning was from
our weekly meeting we have a meeting
Wednesday nights this is not an
invitation with me Tim and Peter Peter
of course is on the TV because he's in
Sweden and we are here in Melbourne
Australia every week Wednesday nights we
have a meeting for a couple hours
usually we talk about what we've done in
the last week what we're going to do in
the next week it's kind of like almost
like a Sprint meeting like a scrum
situation but it's way more laid back
and chilled than that and yeah we just
hang out as well and it's a kind of a
good I guess team building experience
since Peter isn't here with us in the
flesh
almost sounds like he died it is no
longer with us
sorry Peter uh and then I'm probably
gonna try and focus on a bit of a theme
for each kind of devlog so that there's
something to talk about so I'm finally
getting to talking about multi-threading
today so that will be later in the video
the other thing that the team is
currently working on is we're working
towards a release so we have not updated
like our Master branch of Hazel the
Hazel that's available for patrons like
the big proper version of Hazel that
we're building we haven't updated the
master Branch for that in like I think
eight months and so we've got all these
new features that have gone into the dev
Branch but they haven't been properly
tested and we can't really do a release
until that's done so after months of
work and lots of bug fixes and all that
stuff like we have finally we're
basically ready for a release so
hopefully at the end of this week if not
then next week we'll be doing our first
kind of release where we merge that into
the master branch and that will
kind of be a new version of Hazel I
guess which is exciting and that's what
Tim's doing right now I'm writing the
changelog for Hazel
um what has gone in and out of Hazel in
the last like six to eight months
because there's a release coming up look
at that that's a lot
yeah it's funnily enough whoa that's bug
fixes this is a bug fixes section which
is half of the release notes we sure do
write a lot of bugs
and then fix them
file names that are too big shouldn't
render the whole string yeah fix that
today oh wow if I go back to the
generation
look at those
but have a look I fixed it today
you're showing me a bug that I never
knew existed and then look it works
right so you can resize it and it just
puts a dot in yep
it's little things it's the details that
make hazel great yep
when are we releasing this
uh this week
this week yep damn if plans haven't
changed
should be this week are you asking me I
was looking at you to confirm plus I
would show you all right I'm gonna show
you guys uh what the deal is with
multi-threading because we basically
have multi-threading in a sense in Hazel
now this is something I mentioned in
like the last devlog the last normal
kind of devlog before we started this
exciting new devlog series uh this is
Hazel's editor hazelnut if I just hit
play you can see this is dichotomy the
last game we made for the last ladum
dare game Jam that we did what you see
here
is
running single threaded we use something
called optic for
um like profiling so if I just record
this for a bit it'll connect to Hazel we
can kind of see what's going on
um I'm gonna try and like do some zooms
and stuff so that you guys can see this
a bit more clearly but we'll see how it
goes so basically what this is is every
single uh frame that was captured during
me kind of hitting play and then stop if
we look at any given frame there's two
threads that are running kind of I guess
more or less permanently we have a main
thread and we have an audio thread now
uh audio is we won't talk about audio
because
um that's kind of a thing a thing of its
own but this main thread
um
is basically responsible for the entire
CPU side
of operations that go into a single
frame in Hazel minus audio and then
these kind of things you see here these
are all function calls uh well not all
of them actually some of them are like
Scopes because you can add like a little
uh you know tag so that it profiles you
know like whatever's between a scope not
necessarily a function but most of them
are functions that we call and the way
that Hazel was kind of written from the
ground up there's so many things to talk
about so I'm gonna see how I go here but
basically you can kind of see what's
going on
um if we look at one frame let's just
focus on this Frame here so this Frame
went for seven milliseconds uh you can
see that it starts with the Hazel
renderer weight and render
um which we'll get to later and then it
ends with this on update now in reality
it kind of happens in Reverse but the
idea is that Hazel editor layer on
update is where the entire kind of
application frame stems from so it does
a lot of critical tasks such as you know
rendering the whole viewport and all of
the kind of associated UI and playing
the game and doing whatever you're doing
kind of for that frame now even though
this says Hazel scene on render editor
this doesn't actually do really any of
the rendering instead of what it does is
it actually submits it into something
called a render command queue and that
as you can probably guess gets evaluated
or executed here so Hazel renderer
weight and render what this function
does is basically just goes through the
queue of commands that have been
submitted from this kind of Hazel scene
on render editor and it will go through
and actually execute those commands and
that might include things like executing
Vulcan draw calls so issuing Vulcan draw
calls so that we can actually like draw
geometry and do whatever it is that we
need to do and really you can
arbitrarily submit anything you want
into this queue now Hazel worked with
this render command queue from like the
beginning so years ago when I first
wrote Hazel and I first wrote like the
renderer and the application system it
had this like immediately but as you can
see it doesn't make much sense to have
this if you're just running everything
on one thread because what you have is
uh you know basically you kind of I
guess submitting all the commands and
then after that's done you evaluate all
the commands and if you're having
trouble visualizing this because it
shows the weight and render first you
can just kind of skip over to the next
frame and see kind of how that works so
where's that frame boundary here it is
so you can see like after this there's
another uh weight and render so
basically everything that gets submitted
here gets executed here as part of this
weight and render and it's called wait
and render because it was designed with
multi-threading in mind weight meaning
that it's possible that it might have to
wait if it's still waiting on commands
to be submitted because it's finished
its previous frame early now hopefully
this is beginning to maybe make sense as
to what we could do with this kind of
power that we have here what we could do
is we could basically submit all the
commands over here and then cut out the
weight and render because we'll do that
on another thread and immediately jump
from here all the way to this next kind
of on update that we actually have to do
over here
so
the idea is that this weight and render
can actually be done in parallel with
this now how can it be done in parallel
with this if it's like if this is
happening here if this is submitting
commands through there how can we do it
in parallel well the idea is that the
render thread which is what does render
away and render and executes all the
commands that runs one frame behind so
the main thread is always kind of one
frame ahead what it does is it submits
commands it submits any arbitrary and by
commands I'm really just talking about
code like you're just saying I want you
to do this but on your own thread when
you're ready all you do is you submit
you know you do any other kind of main
thread related application tasks that
might be outside of rendering of course
but then when it comes time to render
you just submit the commands for
rendering and then what happens is those
commands are executed when you finish
your frame over here you kind of Kick
the render thread and you tell it hey
now you can start executing those
commands I submitted so what happens is
you end up with the main thread being
say at frame 0 then the frame changes to
frame one and that's when the render
thread starts executing frame zero and
only after that's kind of done do you
continue on to you know application
frame two render a frame one now of
course these can finish early either of
them it depends like if your render
thread bound or main thread bound
meaning what thread is taking more time
what thread is holding the other thread
back so of course if you do finish early
then one of the threads will just kind
of wait and do nothing could be the
render thread could be the main thread
but you can never kind of have them not
be this distance apart so you can't have
the main thread run ahead because that
wouldn't make sense like the the user
needs kind of visual feedback so they
can make decisions in their game you
can't just pre-submit a hundred frames
and then play them out like a replay but
then also the render thread can't
possibly go in front of the main thread
because the main thread is the one
that's telling it what to do so it has
to wait for instructions now this is a
very common approach in game engines and
applications for like
I want to say decades but probably
around one decade maybe in Hazel because
we use Vulcan we don't strictly have to
stick to executing Vulcan commands only
on the render thread whereas if you use
something like opengl because opengl has
to be tied to just one thread it can't
you can't multi-thread it if you try and
use it from another thread that's not
allowed you basically end up with your
opengl render context on that render
thread and then the main thread submits
everything to it uh or you might even
need to have your opengl contacts on the
main thread so back when I worked at EA
on the mobile engine on Android for
example I don't know if it was like
certain Android drivers or devices but
we basically had to have openglb on the
main thread so instead of like creating
an additional render thread for opengl
we created an additional main thread an
additional application thread I guess
and the main thread was the render
thread because it had to be but with
Vulcan we can be very flexible of course
you can have more than one thread you
can execute Vulcan commands on the main
thread and in fact we do do that for
some things you can have an additional
like resource loading thread for for
example that can actually copy stuff and
submit it to like the transfer queue or
whatever to get stuff onto GPU memory
the possibilities are endless and that's
one of the reasons why Balkan and
DirectX 12 are just such powerful apis
okay so I kind of said that this was
multi-threader but then I said it's
single threaded so what's going on so
what I did was I was a little bit lazy
not really lazy but
I actually didn't get around to uh
making the hazelnut editor multi-thread
it because that requires I'm GUI to work
with kind of multi-threading and I'm GUI
does not work with multi-threading now I
have got it to work in a separate Branch
years ago and I can demonstrate that if
you guys are interested I might make a
video just talking about multi-threading
I'm GUI but uh I didn't get around doing
it for this and also I figured like you
know when you're making a game engine
and when you're focusing on on
prioritizing software development
one of the most important things you
have to consider is the impact on the
user now for a game engine there might
be several users there might be the
people who build the games using the
game engine but I think for the most
part people would think of like the
players of the games as like your
primary clients so you obviously use the
engine to make a game but then you ship
that game and then the players those are
the kind of primary group of people you
care about so I figured well our runtime
doesn't have I'm GUI at all so why don't
we just make the runtime multi-threaded
at least to begin with because sure the
editor would of course be faster if it
was multi-threaded and we could do
things potentially quicker but to be
honest performance has been fine it
hasn't been like a huge pain point for
us and really we would want the players
of our games to kind of experience the
benefits and the improved performance
first so if I just kind of close this
out and uh I'll just start up the
runtime instead I should probably mute
this because it'll probably have some
music
let me just mute the music Sorry I know
I wrote it and you guys want to hear it
because it's beautiful but we'll get to
that later so this is dichotomy running
in like the normal kind of Hazel run
time right the snow I'm GUI this is like
the published game kind of it's still
like a release build not a disc build so
there are some differences but uh if we
just hit enter to play or whatever and
then we hit Ctrl F3 you can see here
that we have uh controller three just
shows some details as you can see by the
way nothing too uh fancy but you can see
that we have a main thread and we have a
render thread and we can actually see
kind of what is waiting on what now this
is actually showing that the render
thread is waiting for 0.57 milliseconds
which I'm I'm actually gonna go ahead
and say that I don't think that's true
this is much more likely the main thread
is waiting on the render thread because
the main thread is taking 1.02
milliseconds Which is less than 1.93 and
then it's waiting for 0.91 milliseconds
which is the difference between 1.02 and
1.93 so I don't know what this is this
might be like some kind of bug let's
just get to that but basically uh yeah
we have two threads it results in a
faster CPU time so this is our CPU frame
time and this is our GPU frame time
because of course the frame needs to
actually be rendered on the GPU as well
so you could look at this and you could
say okay where's CPU bound at 3.71
milliseconds or whatever because that's
above the GPU now if you take a look at
this you might think that okay sure 3.71
milliseconds these two numbers uh if it
really is multi-threaded like this
should basically be the frame time why
is this not 1.93 milliseconds why is it
3.71 and to be completely honest I
probably couldn't
really tell you why uh I think that it's
it might come down to how this is timed
it might come down to other threads that
might be slowing it down it I don't I I
also think that this main thread
measurement is not the entire
application frame it's just the game so
basically like all the scene rendering
that happens on the main threads of the
submission you know going through every
entity updating all the c-sharp scripts
I think that's what this is there might
be external kind of you know things in
that that aren't included because
they're not really game specific they
might be like hazel back end kind of
window management or whatever related
but that's probably worth kind of
investigating or at least showing what
the difference is there
but you can still see that obviously if
we add these two numbers together we'll
get like 3.9 or whatever so that's still
higher than this and also this might be
from a frame in front of this so you can
see if I just let it run like it kind of
fluctuates but what we can also do is
open up Optik here
and just give that a record right so if
I record this because I'm running a
release build by the way if I was
running a distribution build of course
you can't profile with optic because
optic is stripped and all the profiling
stuff is stripped from the from the
build obviously but here you can see
what's going on so you can see we
actually have two threads now we have a
main thread we have a render thread you
can see that we're actually bound here
by the main thread which is almost a bit
funny because those timers seem to have
been telling a different story so that's
a bit weird but uh what this is showing
is that a frame is like around 3.8
milliseconds for example we have all of
this let me just zoom in maybe in Optics
so we can see one frame a bit a bit
better so you can see we have the kind
of on update runtime on render runtime
so this will basically update all the
c-sharp scripts uh and like the physics
and stuff like that render runtime will
submit every single entity which is
what's happening here and then in the
next frame which if we just go to the
previous frame uh the render thread will
go through and actually you know issue
Vulcan draw calls and all that stuff and
do much more other stuff like gather
materials and whatever to make sure that
we can actually render you know what was
submitted kind of from here so this
stuff that's being submitted is kind of
executed uh here I guess that's how that
works uh and yeah that results in in
Faster performance because you can see
that we're now doing these things like
kind of on top of each other right like
if you look at this block here
especially this is like this is us
literally doing things in parallel at
the exact same point in time rather than
one after the other like we were doing
with single threaded now I could talk
about this a lot more I might do a deep
dive video or something about this let
me know what you guys think like in the
comment section below there are
definitely some issues we need to iron
out this is a devlog this is not like a
fully finished presentation and a
research paper that I've spent the last
few years on this work in progress as
always and I guess that's what I'm
trying to do with this series as well
just try and show stuff and not really
care if it works perfectly or whatever
not try and give the illusion of
perfection of course there's lots of
moving parts and lots of things that we
probably still need to do but that is up
and running and of course this code like
is pushed into the dichotomy branch in
our repository so if you're a patron you
can experiment with this play around
with it yourselves I do kind of want to
talk about the code and show you the
code I'm not trying to be secretive with
The Code by the way although you can get
it on patreon of course and support the
project that would be nice but it's just
more so that uh that that's going to be
like an hour and I want to keep these
devlogs a bit short so I might do a deep
dive and I might ah I don't know
honestly like maybe I I was thinking of
releasing exclusive videos for patrons
at like a lower tier so that it's more
accessible to you guys where I can just
maybe just talk for an hour and actually
show like the code and not care about
editing or whatever that's like for the
people who really really want want that
but I'm also happy to give just like a
an overview of how it works here on
YouTube as well without like spending
hours on it so yeah let me know what you
want to see because at this point it's
more for you than for me